my odds are 1 to 23. you guys if you bet
on me and i win you'll become a
millionaire
[Music]
this is going to be awesome here and the
game should be beginning
shortly so you know you know charlie
better than any
one here at thechest.com streaming
community how how uh how pumped is he
to be back here uh in pog champs and and
uh
what what chances you give him to maybe
be one of the better players
he's definitely pumped that i know he's
also definitely nervous and
i always point this out these uh stars
these streamers
they are used to broadcasting to
millions and millions of people danny
but there's something about sitting
behind a chess board
be it a virtual chess board or a real
chessboard that brings out all the
anxiety and i actually really like that
so charlie he's experienced
he knows what this is like at the same
time
we're going to watch his time
consumption and uh i don't know
too much about code miko but i think
she's put in the work
well right now she started out pretty
pretty well she played some natural
developing moves right i mean this is
um not the most traditional approach
against the sicilian and charlie handles
it like a pro with e6 and d5 but but
there's some risk in an opening like
this if if miko can
can play aggressively in the center
early on maybe she'll maybe she'll be
okay here
yeah for sure she needs to strike in the
center d4
get her pieces out quickly rookie once
she goes d3 she's doing everything right
preparing the development of her dark
square bishop and charlie
quickly focusing on getting that king to
safety
uh by castling yeah bishop v7
supernatural move but this is
this is a great start i mean even though
we were saying d4 i actually kind of
like that she played d3 because it
protects against c4 maybe maybe she
she would have got her bishop trap so
this is some really awesome principal
chess she's bringing out her pieces and
all right now i'm nervous i'm excited
i'm excited too this is great
and they're both getting their pieces
out doing everything right mikko brings
her last piece out charlie still has
that dark
light squared bishop to bring out which
he can put on a bunch of different
squares
and they are following the fundamentals
to the letter gaming
yeah and you know something about the
way she's playing two just the tempo of
it right even if this is
the most traditional approach against
charlie sicilian she's playing all these
developing moves with confidence if you
look at the fact that she has nine and a
half minutes
so i'm going to do the early kind of
hecarim call to action and just say
i kind of think she's underrated at 3 33
he tends to kind of look at the ratings
and see how they play and i
i would say now that she's probably
underrated at 300.
she absolutely is and i completely agree
with you
just by these first moves uh she's
showing complete command of the
fundamentals and uh
you don't do that you know if you're if
you've had one chess lesson so she's
definitely been putting in the work now
charlie
um i'm gonna be straight up with you
danny he he has a big weakness in terms
of his time consumption
when he's playing casually he he plays
confidently but when he's on the big
stage
sometimes he freezes so we'll see
whether he can uh he can control that
here in this game i'm not gonna do
anything too crazy here
he's illuminating even his thoughts here
tanya
so deep you can't express them so do you
express that right i'm just gonna say we
don't care about double pawns
let's let's come back here to the main
board and i
played bishop f4 and point one i'm
pretty sure she had accidentally clicked
it for a pre-move
or she or she was pre-moving which would
be you know kind of a surprise kind of
uh you know high-level play there for
her to pre-move and and maybe not a very
smart one with with
charlie playing b5 but let's throw to
code miko now for the first time and see
what she's thinking about it's okay it's
fine
oh my god here he comes here comes the
pummeling guys
um
the pummeling i have not been looking
forward to
but kinda yes
oh jesus that's scary
all right well i guess we'll have oh
jesus that's not good
um um you know what
you know what guys you know what
i'm just spence
i'm just gonna go
here
not a great move yep
uh hey more than six news okay
probably does it
all right
that's what she's missed
oh
she's playing so fast that's that's the
thing that i would advise her yep
oh
shut up shut up everyone oh wait what
oh i didn't even
oh i didn't even say hey
you know what guys you know what we
we did it it was more than six moves
that's that's for
are we sure dreamers do we dream
or do we meme
we do both when we dream a meme at the
same time there's nothing we cannot do
we can achieve
everything you heard it you heard it
from code miko
if you dream and meme anything's
possible dreaming and memeing together
is a win
here we go it's going to be an awesome
day we got mystery ludwig up ahead we
got crazy stuff charlie plays e4
here we go and an e5 from code miko and
the vienna
gambit is what charlie has been playing
over the last couple of weeks that's
where white goes f4
pretty quickly but here he develops his
vision
yeah this is a really aggressive line
right obviously when you play f4 at some
point the f-file will lead
the rook and bishop having a date right
there on f7 or at least they hope to
and the pressure becomes very very very
very strong very quickly depending on
whether black knows what to do so
mikko already given it a think right
here
right it's not the most common opening
which is part of the reason that uh it's
very effective because if you can get
your opponent out of their
comfort zone pretty early and you know
the ideas you get a pretty big edge on
the clock and
often that translates into an advantage
over the board right
well now already white has the option to
play f4
and you can also play d3 if you still
want to sort of slow jam the idea
um of course you always have the option
of going back into a more traditional
kind of whatever that would be two
nights four nights
but no as we already we already know
because uh because we have the profit
here f4
is charlie's weapon what do you think is
gonna happen at some point in the event
when he plays against someone who's
prepared for his vienna how's that gonna
go
well he's gonna have to tighten up the
screws because the thing with these
openings right if they work out for you
you can score some quick victories
if you mess up the move order you mess
up one move it's a double-sided sword
and you can get in trouble pretty darn
fast but uh so far charlie's showing
nice command of the principles getting
rid of the pin immediately
yeah and the risk as you said because if
it goes wrong what you've done
is open up a lot of dark squares but
okay here we see
an example of how it goes right a lot a
lot of times people don't
really realize how aggressive this line
can be and just like that your bishop is
trapped
yeah kodmiko bishop trapped on one side
of the board and now it's strapped on
the other side of the board in the other
game
and she does the right thing giving it
up for a pawn if you're losing a piece
you want to give it up for as much as
possible
yeah she takes it that's a good move and
i and i again i think the only thing i
would say
is obviously it's hard you know when you
when you feel like you're playing a
stronger player
but i think that she maybe like we said
in game one thinks she's a little worse
than she
is and and is playing kind of too fast
if she if she slows down a little bit
you know um because the openings she's
had are very principled right she's
gotten pieces out she understands all of
those all of those development
kind of ideas and we'll see if she gets
castled here
it's the king of the center yeah she's
she's developing all our pieces and you
can't say it enough
it's not that easy to get into a
situation we have command of the
principles and
that's exactly what she has maybe again
maybe taking a little bit more time
would have been good
but these unconventional positions they
can be hard to get your footing in but
other than that
you know you could confuse or play for
that of magnus or maybe gary caspara
yeah i mean what would gary kasparov
think about this position
well if only we had him on the show but
danny
tim this reminds me of the match against
uh
another corporate
do you think you think good russian
school boys gary was a busy man
would good russian school boys
appreciate the v tuber experience you
think
gary any
you know where i come from and i would
say be too worrying is i'm old school
you know i like
flip phones you know notebooks in a
button
i can definitely appreciate you know the
the sort of the rise you know the ai
and you know i've spoken about it even
in colleges in it before but um
overall you know i'm quite approving of
you know the strength
okay there you go thank you gary um
we'll uh maybe check in with you a
little bit later all right look at this
move knight h5 from her
mikko puts that in on h5 it opens up the
check and we see charlie make his first
kind of odd move of the day let's listen
into code miko and see if she sees the
check and what she can do here drawing
is important
but that's gonna get that guy so
then you
uh no i wanna i wanna get rid of some of
my
some of my pieces are so stuck and
that night on h5
exactly
oh [ __ ] i know what he's trying to do
he's trying to
okay okay okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait i get what he's trying to do
um just depend on that one don't worry
don't don't panic don't panic everybody
don't panic okay don't panic
just don't panic nobody panic
it's okay nobody panic
i'm not either no uh
nobody i don't understand why i can't
move this
but um nobody panic stop penegate
okay stop yelling danny why are you
panicking danny
why are you panicking now we'll see if
charlie
can see how dangerous the g-file is the
uh computer's actually announcing bait
and six but let's see what charlie sees
yeah and what you can see here white is
up two pieces and there's also this
g-file
white's got a rook positioned and facing
right at black's king
and that pawn that is covering the king
is very flimsy you can attack that pawn
with a variety of pieces you can bring
your bishop out all the way to age six
and the pawn because it is binge of king
yeah the he's not he's not talking i
don't know how best to approach this
mate
this is something i also need to work on
i see a lot of different mating options
here
i see a ton of mating options i just
don't know
like the best and fastest way of doing
it
i'm just gonna push it up that's the
best move
that's the fastest mate got it easy
queen is untouchable because of the
thing to me that looks okay if she comes
here i can just take the bishop
he's nervous he's worried there's a
defensive resource somewhere
but there isn't any
do i want to just take that with any of
the three pieces actually
doing her best block the g file but
unfortunately it's just
hold the pin oh yep now it's and now
it's made on g7
and there it is
wow that was a commanding attack there
by charlie he did not
real talk he was he was awesome so
charlie just one quick question
for you do you feel uh similar to how
you did in pogchamps when do you feel
like that experience is making you less
nervous or is it
the sort of same kind of sensation oh
absolutely not i think it's a lot more
nerves this time because
i won the the losers bracket the
consolation participation trophy bracket
and now i'm like
almost expected to win some games and i
think that sucks that
is tough man having to play with like an
expectation to do well
oh i was really really excited i'm super
nervous to go against
like literally chess jesus himself um
but i was just really happy that i did
more than six moves
yeah no i think that's great that was
one of the finest performances i've seen
in pogchamps typically i'm slapping
cheeks around six moves
you went all the way to like 12 in some
cases
yay that's why i'm saying go more if we
just do more than six moves we're
winning for me today amen
exactly these were good games good start
to the event and best of luck in in the
next round
thank you so much thanks for having me
you